Seth Greenberg ESPN college basketball
analyst and joining his Continental Tire
Coaches Corner a coach let me start here
I just had an unbelievably white-hot
take on who's the best player in the
draft whoo I like the potential NBA
potential can you guess who I like NBA
potential wise for this draft later this
month well I hope it would be DeAndre
because he's a genetic freak no in terms
of upside he reminds a little bit and
bead but I would like to know your
opinion on who you think is the greatest
potential Dan jaren Jackson jr. the
third oh I'm a big Jerry Jackson fan now
you know in terms of you know that's not
that's not far off
jaren Jackson another guy you talk about
seven five wingspan shoots threes runs
the floor can defend you'd like to see
him rebound a ball better he's got
ridiculous pedigree I'd make you too GM
as long as you don't have multiple
Twitter accounts I'm not gonna take
marquel folds though no no that's
probably not a good you know the
interesting thing is I asked you a bear
for false but you know one thing that I
talked to a lot of people before I
thought Tatum last year was the best
player I mean I'd to me in terms of
transitional skillset yeah but like I
talked to Jim Boeheim who I think
evaluates as good as any player a coach
I've ever talked to in terms of just
having a feel for players and he you
know he was involved with faults with
USA basketball and he swore by the kid
and he and I actually had a pretty
heated argument about it one day on the
phone and uh but you know faults we
don't know yet I mean obviously he has
some issues he has some maturity issues
but you never know how it's gonna play
it we still forget these kids are 18 19
years old I mean they're not a finished
product mentally physically emotionally
the transition to having money having
freedom and having pressure so I mean I
think sometimes we overreact to one year
you know I hate to use the word because
I think it's the whole thing's kind of a
joke but it's not as easy as it looks
and it is a process to some well you
don't have finished products coming out
of college like we once did when you had
somebody with at least three years of
experience maybe four years of
experience and that wasn't a negative
you know 20 years ago
you're trying to assess a kid who's 18
years of age 19 years of age even 20
years of age
sounds like an old kid coming out of
college so it makes it even tougher when
you have these high draft picks that you
just can't live on them and that's where
this is gonna be on Bryan Colangelo the
rest of his career that because we're
gonna look at Jason Tatum and every time
you see him you go how the Sixers pass
on that guy how did they pass on Jason
Tatum I don't know I'm not I I think why
did you pass on Steph Curry we didn't
have a scholarship available that's why
I mean we you got somebody get ready run
somebody off to give him a scholarship
right or we weren't allowed that we well
we ended up with plenty of scholarships
available but I we weren't allowed to
over award that's just the way it was in
our schools so but anyway I know in
terms of you know you know you looking
at Tatum I mean it's amazing Tatum just
his size his length is feel his you know
I hate that the cliches that the Scott
and gurus use but no scores at all three
levels but the guys wired the score and
he does have a lot of different ways to
make buckets so that's why I like Tatum
but it's an exact science and you're
right the problem is that the analytics
guys say that you know there's a big
difference drafting in eighteen year old
and the 21 year old that the 18 year
olds up side far exceeds where a player
is at 21 which is mind-boggling to me
because 21 is far from the finished
product and you know I'd love to see the
data but I was talking to a bunch of NBA
guys just the other day and they said
that there is a difference now you can't
make mistakes I mean it's just it's such
a valuable commodity to draft it out at
the top and I like your Jackson pick I'd
like to see him rebound the ball better
he's Marcus Camby with a jumper that's
my that's my comparison all right I'll
take that I'll take that here's another
thing that I was looking at the Cavs
sitting there at number eight is there a
player because you're not gonna know
what LeBron is gonna do free agency wise
is there a player that you can take who
can compliment LeBron but also if LeBron
leaves you can give him a little bit
more of the piece of the team yeah you
know what I don't think there isn't a
time it's interesting
I mean we talked about Collin Sexton
yesterday and and you know to me I'm not
crazy about Collin Sexton I think he's
explosive these kind of an eric bledsoe
jay whould jay williams type player
you're physically strong tax explosive
not a great shooter not a great decision
maker but when you get past the bigs and
let's say some top of the draft is gonna
be loaded with bigs you've got guys that
are all ifs I mean they got there
they're gonna be good players they can
be very good players there could be
all-stars but when you start going
through it Mikkel Bridges is a spot-up
shooter a good defender a guy with
laylani Walker's a freakish athlete
Myles bridges is changing positions Shea
gilts Alexander is this six six point
guard would feel Robert Williams you
don't even know he loves basketball you
start going through the players that are
available
you know Michael Porter could drop now
you know he's difficult to play with
from what people say he's got to have
the ball in his hands but he is talented
there are good players after seven and
eight very good players guys will being
a legal long time I don't know how many
all-stars are in that group though oh
and that's in the finding Donovan
Mitchell I think that everyone here has
signed Donovan Mitchell and you know
like Bruce Brown to Kidd at Miami like I
like him as a potential Donovan Mitchell
type guy that didn't have a great
sophomore year because he was hurt shot
a better his freshman year freakish
athlete good floor game can defend in a
great work ethic high character six nine
wingspan he's my Donovan Mitchell type
for this draft Seth Greenberg ESPN
college basketball analyst joining us
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
wingspan is the big phrase and watch it
watching the draft special last night
everybody was six six with a 72 wingspan
he's six nine with a seven five wingspan
mo Bamba has a 710 wingspan it's crazy
yeah wingspan is bad because you know
weight wingspan and that you know
impacts the game so many different ways
I mean like kata beats me up seven you
know four or five wingspan because of
the position les MBA
and the new MBA where you plan smaller
you're seeing more switching you're
seeing guys that can obviously use their
legs
to get deflections you know use their
length to rebound the basketball
draymond Green has changed the NBA
because draymond Green guards two to
five actually one to five
Trevor mine Green can play Center Fred
times for Golden State at six six in a
lot of ways the NBA is looking more and
more like European basketball in a three
at four and a four or five if I if I
gave you the choice you had to pick klay
Thompson or draymond Green well I would
pick dry him on great because draymond
Green is a connector by klay Thompson is
a specialist yeah
Leigh Thompson obviously does something
as well as anyone in the game but
draymond Green impacts the game every
single time down the floor on both ends
he bounced the ball he initiates a
fast-break he can pick him pop he's a
willing ear he makes it the next pass
he's deep and like think about early in
the houston series like he jacked up
harden that was that was on purpose now
I mean he says like he sent a message to
everyone his edge he's the voice of that
locker room and Kevin Durant's
ridiculous doesn't say much Steph
Curry's ridiculous doesn't he'll give
you the shimmy and all that but he
doesn't impact others draymond Green
impacts your team and the other team if
you could have LeBron or Kevin Durant
for the next four years who I think I
would take Kevin Durant I can't imagine
LeBron and here's my thing 82 games or
100 games now in the amount of minutes
that he played for four more years
he can't do that I know I it's it look
he's incredible he's a he's a specimen
like no other we've ever seen and he
works at his trade like no on net that
we've ever seen in terms of his
conditioning Kevin Durant his body type
I think he plays forever he's younger
he's a more consistent shot maker
I think he's easier to play with you
even know LeBron is going to just take
over a series and win again
are way too serious for you but if
you're talking for years yeah the amount
of mileage on LeBron James
I mean he's changed the tires four times
I mean I mean he's been I mean it's
amazing the amount of Medicine has
played here's another one for you if if
you're the Lakers why would you bring in
land you're no ball you know what I have
no idea might get rid of Lonzo ball so
forget about bringing in the Angelo ball
I mean lots of balls not worth his
problems does that work for you I like
Alec Lanza ball had a nice rookie year
he's Ricky Rubio he rebounds it he can
shoot it I mean he can pass it he sees
plays early he's got a feel for it
unbelievable feel for the gaming tonight
but I mean until he gets a middle game
and until he until he can show that he
could actually shoot more than 30% from
2/3 consistently
he's a really good player and I know
he's only 19 years old then the other
question is is he more interested in his
music that is basketball like at this
age he should be totally invested in his
game it seems like he's invested in his
music game as much as it basketball game
I just can't have his dad involved in
another player when when he just
publicly criticized the medical staff
with the Lakers and now you're gonna get
unless you're doing this to placate dad
and Lonzo you're gonna bring in lanzhou
just to work him out because I don't
even know if Lee Angelo is an NBA player
he's got an MBA please he was when I was
in Long Beach State I wouldn't recruit a
little ball all right we know we have
good players we have pros he's a good
shooter he can make sure he's not an NBA
player I mean that's that you're talking
about fiction he says look I'm sure he's
a great kid you know I was looking to be
in that environment I made a bad
decision no doubt about it spent time in
Lithuania which is like you know
basically being in purgatory you know
but like NBA player you these guys were
so he's not an NBA player I'm not just
the way it is he can't beat you off the
bounce he's not guarding anyone he's got
a little toughness to him he can shoot
it but I mean that to me
Lavar ball is talks
that's just the way it is because he has
an agenda look I'm all for it parents be
involved in their kids lives I think
it's great but you can't be toxic in the
NBA maybe one do you know one other
parent in the NBA besides mrs. Durant
who gives her son a hug after games
drayman's mom yeah dream on smile but
but but not the same way she's involved
she's involved she's calling out Kevin
Durant like ISO ball like she's she's
telling Twitter I mean like this guy's
wife that he's worth it though you know
Dre money is worth any trouble that goes
along with it
Lonzo hasn't proven that he could be
yeah and he's not the trouble it's just
dad that you know it's not worth right
but here's the deal you're right but but
they're connected at the hip oh I know
oh by the way you know anyone has bought
any pair of those sneakers I don't how
nervous would that make you if you were
recruiting so your college coach and you
go in and you see dad would you continue
to recruit no matter how good that kid
is after you meet that it's gotta be
better than dads problems I thought
Steve offered he was never an issue at
UCLA now absolutely had a magical season
yeah until the end of the season when he
took a shot at EJ leaf and Thomas Welch
yeah which I thought was I could you
imagine I mean that was so awful the
things you saved my poster guys it's
ridiculous but no I mean the kids gotta
be better than his problems and and you
know it's weird it's just to me it's so
strange to see an MBA players parent
that involved and we look we give them
the platform whether it's yes I heard
ESP adder and he understands how to use
that and he's made money off it which is
you know look like I don't mind parents
that are involved I do have a problem
with people that are mean-spirited and
like to me that it's not fun and games
when you're misogynistic it's not fun
and games when you're talking about
someone else's child it's not fun and
games when you're pointing fingers at
people's professions not because of
knowledge but more because you're trying
to you know empower you you know
yourself and your kids
when you bring other people in the
conversation to me that's mean-spirited
so like I have no like being a involved
parent and he's obviously raised really
nice kids and I guess I think Leah made
a bad decision but I'm not sure that's
who he is
but he always brings other people into
the conversation and and and to me it's
like when I was coaching I when I had a
parent called me I talked about you know
how could that makes social anything
else but I can't talk to you about
basketball because once basketball comes
to the equation someone else's son comes
into conversation and that parent is not
there to defend his son I'll leave you
with this how surprised were you that
Dante de Vincenzo decided that he was
going into the drug yeah he had to after
after after a compound but here's the
deal and I love dr. D Vincenzo my
daughter's a Villanova grad graduate two
years ago but here's my Dante issue he
is great he's a shop maker he's tough to
me he's got a little Bobby Sur in him
but let me ask you this have you watched
the West Virginia game and those and
Javon Carter and those guys absolutely
get up and underneath him yes watch that
game yeah yeah
what would your opinion be of it well I
I don't know about dribbling the ball in
traffic I think it's got incredible
athleticism and you know he's got range
you're not afraid to take to the hoop
but I I don't know he's not up he's not
a point guard no he's a shot maker he's
kind of a microwave hot guy I think the
biggest thing today is we Kevin herder
what happens with him and those Kentucky
kids what do they do
I think those are the two bigger big
conversations today you got four players
from Kentucky that have to minimization
I know and you get and then you've got
Kevin herder who is good Marilyn yes you
know he's no different name was all
seasoned and I mean like people lost
their mind at the combine he's a shot
making guys a high basketball IQ but
it's no different than it was during the
season yeah he just made shots a good
stuff Seth keep firing it up all right
brother let's on Seth Greenberg for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the
and Patrick show ass
[Music]